no but had you ever met any of the cats
before doing the movie I used to work at
the Four Seasons Hotel in Beverly Hills
so you still wait on some of these guys
as a waiter bladers but you waited on
who I waited on anywhere from you know
Nicole Kidman to to Al Pacino to Robert
De Niro and fast forward now 2019-20
I'm in a movie with these guys so I
worked a lot of people start to give up
they start to give up and they go
whatever okay I lean into something else
my backup plan or something and that's a
really incredible story that's really
inspiring yeah well I had no backup plan
no I didn't even was either this or
streets so yeah I when I came out to LA
in 1998 it was stand-up comedy or bus so
yeah I worked there seven and a half
years waited on all of Hollywood and now
things are finally paying off so yeah I
bet you all of them were waiters at some
point too I feel like we were all where
waitress were you a good waiter I was
not only a waiter
I was selling satellite dishes out of
the kiosk in the ghetto so I sold vacuum
cleaners for two days is that right
uh-huh no I was like mmhmm yeah the dirt
and it was like you know what no I
couldn't do it we all had these jobs I
used to glazed ham at honey baked ham oh
my gosh those are good honey baked ham
[Applause]
no we we get those birds like Christmas
and Thanksgiving not kidding they're so
good yeah I glazed them nicely done
you're a great at play 60 it's all this
that builds to where you are now I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this